[Musique]
il est au coeur de cette bataille contre
l'épidémie dr karl weiss est avec nous
dr weiss bonsoir on l'a senti dans le
ton du premier ministre quand il annoncé
les dix décès de plus totale de 18 décès
que il va falloir qu'ils s'habituent pas
c'est triste et il accusait lé choc que
c'est le genre de nouvelle qui est
incontournable dans ce set histoire
qu'est ce que ça vous dit vous le nombre
de décès par rapport aux cadeaux qu'on
est à 1 % de décès qu'est ce que ça vous
dit d'abord un décès c'est toujours un
décès de trop malheureusement mais sa
boutique on a quand même on s'attendait
à voir 1% mortalité regarder ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays
en italie en espagne en france et des
pays où le taux de mortalité est
beaucoup plus élevé malheureusement il
va y avoir des décès c'était inévitable
et avec le nombre de cas qui augmente
c'est pour ça que ces mesures-là ont été
prises c'est pas et alors les gens sont
frappés maintenant par la réalité des
chiffres c'est à dire au début ça
pourrait paraître obscur quand on disait
aux gens on va mettre des mesures de
confinement restez chez vous on ferme
les écoles les gens pourraient se dire
et pourquoi on fait tout ça je comprends
qu ailleurs l'espace des affaires mais
peut-être qu'il se passera rien chez
nous voilà maintenant les gens sont
confrontés à la réalité qu'au québec
nous on a des décès donc quand vous le
dis ça représente à peu près 1% mais
c'est ça qui était réel
attendu le mois et le pourcentage des
hospitalisations avec 141
hospitalisations dont 50 aux soins
intensifs
on dit que c'est un peu en deçà de ce
qu'on avait prévu cesser votre point de
vue aussi ceux des chiffres très
temporaire et préliminaire qui veulent
dire beaucoup mais pas beaucoup
ça dépend combien vous allez tester de
gens plus vous allez tester deux genres
plus vous allez avoir des gens des
guillemets pas trop malade donc le
nombre total de positive a augmenté et
le nombre de vraiment plus malade bar
tendance attribué proportionnellement
donc une question de nombre l'instant
mais il faut toujours s'assurer que
quand vous avez regardé au québec il ya
trois semaines il y avait très peu de
gens hospitalisés au quasiment personne
pour
la part due à l'infection par le comique
19 et là vous apercevez qu'on ait vendu
déjà à plus d'une centaine vous voyez
que les chiffres augmentent ni relais
dans la forme d' accélération dans la
phase d'accélération de la porte
bon je reviens sur un point on a souvent
discuté ensemble de l'âge des gens qui
sont gravement malade et qui
malheureusement dans certains cas décède
en france il ya une jeune fille qui a
ému toute la france elle s'appelle julie
elle est morte dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi
ça commençait tout doucement et ça s'est
dégradé très rapidement donc on le
rappelle ça peut arriver chez des jeunes
aussi que ça se complique et moins il ya
moins de cas mais ça peut arriver
tout à fait et puis malheureusement
c'est pas juste en france que des gens
qui sont décédés en angleterre aussi en
allemagne et n'a dans d'autres pays où
des jeunes sont décédés il y en a eu
certainement chine on sait que les taux
de mortalité de complications sont
directement liées à l'âge c'est clair
dès que vous dépassez 60 ans sans manche
après 70 ans vraiment plus ça fait 80
ans nettement plus
et puis il me dévoue dépasser 50 par
rapport à 45 ans également et quand vous
tombez le taux de mortalité diminue mais
il n'est pas nul n'est pas zéro cesse
alors ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens
aussi jeune il pour des raisons
probablement génétique et immunologiques
fort que ces gens-là développent des
maladies très sévère et en meurent et
pourquoi dr weiss
justement il ya des gens qui en meurent
et d'autres à côté puis ce fils grégoire
les pouces justin trudeau boris johnson
qui dit qu'à peu près pas de symptômes
en grande bretagne a d'autres pour qui
c'est dur mais je sais pas tant que ça
écoutez ya probablement et en le suspect
mais on n'a pas trouvé la raison il ya
probablement quelque chose de génétique
en arrière de tout ça pourquoi des gens
par exemple dans le sud de l'europe ont
des taux de mortalité beaucoup plus
élevés alors que les gens du nord de
l'europe semble avoir des taux de
mortalité un peu plus bas il ya d'autres
explications méga pas juste les autres
explications
il ya certainement quelque chose penser
que ce virus là a une capacité de
s'attacher aux cellules du poumon mais
pour s'attacher il a besoin d'une
protéine on appelle la protéine s ou
spike c'est comme un spam
vous savez quand on voit ce virus et
vous voyez ces espèces d'arette et
ressort
ruse c'est ce qui permet au virus de
s'attacher aux cellules du poumon est
probablement qu'il ya des gens qui ont
beaucoup plus d'affinités que d'autres
pour que le virus s'attache à leurs
cellules de leurs poumons et ces gens là
ont probablement des marqueurs
génétiques
il favorise cette affinité la très bien
questions du public docteur
qu'arrive-t-il lorsqu'un patient est
admis à l'hôpital aux soins intensifs et
qu'on le met sous ventilateur de quelle
façon
peut-il s'en sortir alors en réalité ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'il faut les laisser
sûrement vous savez pourquoi on l'aimé
sur ordinateur on les met sur
ventilateur pour les aider à respirer
beaucoup m'ont ça sert à quoi vos
poumons c'est ce qui amène d'oxygène
dans votre corps est ce que rejette du
gaz carbone c'est le travail du poumon
quand vous imaginez quand vous allez
avoir de l'inflammation c'est à dire la
l'infection arrive dans vos poumons
vous réagissez à l'affection vous créez
d'inflammation mon petites alvéoles main
il ya des petites alvéoles pulmonaires
normalement c'est de l'air d'un peuvent
se remplir de litige et c'est une équipe
donc liquide
enfin l'oxygène qui est un gaz de passer
au travers de ce liquide adéquatement
donc vous avez des problèmes pour
respirer vous n'arrivez plus à bien vous
enregistrer
alors pour faire ça il faut aider à
respirer donc est ce qu'on va faire un
grosso modo l'âge de simplifie beaucoup
un ventilateur avant qu'il a peur vous
amener plus d'oxygène donc pas monter
l'attenté de ce jeune et va respirer
pour vous et donc va permettre d'être
oxygénée pendant la période critique
vos poumons seront pas capables de le
faire adéquatement et une fois qu'on
espère qu'en vous gardent sous
ventilateur lijour dix jours jo peu
importe la poumon pas cicatrisé donc
comme si vous aviez une coupure et vous
aviez une cicatrice et lorsqu'il va
cicatriser il a il va pouvoir reprendre
son travail et on va pouvoir à ce
moment-là vous étudiez vous enlever leur
ordinateur et vous allez venir à votre
état normal et la guérison sera survenu
parce qu'un des anticorps finalement se
sont développés notre corps a pu
s'éjecter
ce virus là deux choses il se passe que
vous avez les anticorps qui vont
détruire et attaquer le virus mais il ya
aussi le fiqh et après ça il va falloir
réparer le dommage
merritt est due à la guerre entre votre
système immunitaire et le virus parce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est comme un
gars comme une guerre ou à champ de
bataille donc il ya des dégâts et ses
dégâts là il faut les réparer très bien
lorsqu'un vacation 3 lorsque un vaccin
sera découvert devra t-il est
obligatoire pour tous afin de tous nous
protéger à écouter c'est moi je pense
que là on rende en débat des vaccins
obligatoires
je pense que si un vaccin qui est
disponible pour le tableau pour l'heure
cavic 19 et voulait pas de recevoir
ben c'est que vous avez probablement un
problème
la sévérité de la maladie en question
pense que ça va devenir un vaccin
universel et il faut ça devienne un
vaccin universel et ce qui va arriver
votre affaire intentions qui des gens
qui disent pas moi j'aime pas les
vaccins je vais pas me faire vacciner
comme ça tous les autres vont faire
vacciner je vais me faire protéger
indirectement ça va devenir un vaccin
qui va être comme tous les vaccins par
la rougeole qui par exemple est un
vaccin universel et lorsque vous n'êtes
pas protégé vers vous avez des problèmes
alors j'aimerais être capable de vous
dire qu'on a déjà un vaccin alors
j'espère quand on en aura un des gens
vont pas commencer à karen débat sur le
banc le bien fondé de la vaccination
ça sera peut-être pas le moment de
tourner le dos à la science comme vous
le dites avec 7
cette vague cette mode depuis quelques
années de dire que les vaccins sont plus
dangereux que le mal dr weiss merci
beaucoup bonne fin de semaine à vous
garder garder la santé et courage dans
votre hôpital à l'hôpital le jeu de
montréal en trop merci beaucoup de nous
parler